[Music]
we got a few of intel's first actual
gaming gpus the arc gpus this is not a
laptop gimmick strapped onto a pcb
turned into a desktop card like the dg1
this is an actual discrete gaming card
from intel so this is called the a380
this particular card is made by a
company that focuses on the asia market
the company is called gunner and the
model is the photon today we are
reviewing and benchmarking the intel arc
a380 this is exciting because intel
although it's a huge company that
everybody in this audience knows has
never really made a meaningful step into
discrete gpus we'll ignore that some of
the like therapy but this is the
relevant one so this is a 130 to 150
video card if it makes it to every
market right now it's a china only
launch but it might come to the u.s and
they also have an a750 coming up that we
have seen and plugged into a test bench
and even run some benchmarks on you'll
hear more about that later before that
this video is brought to you by
squarespace we use squarespace for our
own gn store and juggle complex
multi-piece orders all the time with it
squarespace makes it fast for us to roll
out new products with detailed pages
full of galleries videos and descriptors
it's also useful for your own resume
sites for photographer or project
portfolios or for starting your new
small business idea there's never been a
better time to try and start your new
business than right now and we can vouch
that squarespace makes it easy visit
squarespace.comgamersnexus to get 10 off
your first purchase with squarespace so
today we're going into the unknown as
the box art says or the khanwa as the
the pre-production one says
they fixed it in the production ones i'm
i'm told i haven't actually seen the box
with the n at the end of the unknown
but apparently they fixed it anyway
attention to detail not a strong point
for the initial launch but hopefully the
gpu does pretty well for this uh the
timing is not particularly good for
intel because right now gpu prices are
plummeting and the gpu supply issue is
largely resolved uh and intel has been
delayed long enough where they really
just had to put something out there
which they're doing except it's at a
time when nvidia is right around the
corner with rtx 40 series and amd is
doing some something not really we're
not sure what yet but there
something will come out of amd at some
point this is a huge story with a ton of
charts we've time stamped it on the
bottom but each benchmark behaves a
little bit differently it's not like
normally where we can draw a wide
sweeping conclusion based on maybe five
or six games because the performance
jumps around a lot and there's some
really unique behaviors with this card
like with resizable bar that we need to
explore there's also ray tracing
functionality that'll be a future piece
pcie lane count is halved this has got
pcie gen 4x8 no by 16 on this one so
lots of unique stuff to look into and it
was a massive undertaking for us to get
this done while running the artesian
build story so if you want to support
our work you can go to
store.gamersnexus.net
to support our independent testing and
reviews and buy things like our limited
edition foil cyber skeleton shirts these
will not be made again once we've sold
through them and they feature cool water
cooling parts for the rib cage design
alongside rgb strips pcie slots and the
back is made of a large print area spine
comprised of mosfets and inductors okay
so first of all nomenclature with these
cards it is pretty straightforward the
three can be thought of as similar to
i3i5 i7 naming it is not the generation
but rather the rank the a is the
generation so that's alchemist the next
one will be b for battle mage you can
think of the letter a like nvidia 30
nvidia 20 and the 7000 amd 6000 the a380
is the lowest end currently launching
with the next ones being the a750 at an
unknown price and probably an a70 or
similar the alchemist gpus currently
launching include the acm g10 and the
acm acmg-11 detailed in this slide the
g11 is the simpler of the two with eight
xe cores and eight rt units so important
information these cards have built-in
ray tracing units we actually detailed
the architecture of the intel arcgpus
previously we'll link that below
and it has the peculiar rebar behavior
and if you need more architectural
information we have both an older arc
video it's all the same though talk
about how the slices and xe cores and
everything else are built and we have an
upcoming video that will go live
tomorrow that includes some a750 shots
and also an interview with one of
intel's engineers uh previously worked
at nvidia give you a hint gaming
benchmarks are up first so for this one
we need to look at rebar resizable base
address register this is a feature
that's been out for a little while now
but it hasn't mattered that much on amd
and nvidia platforms we typically see
maybe a couple percentage points uplift
and amd by the way calls it sam or smart
access memory now for intel this
actually becomes incredibly important
intel even describes a resizable bar or
rebar as basically required for the a380
and likely the a750 and the a7
whatever's after that so
this is something we need to look at on
versus off which is what we'll be
starting with and it's also a feature
that's available on pretty much every
modern platform but if you're looking
for the a380 as maybe a drop in upgrade
for an older platform roller system this
is not going to be a good option for you
let's look at why this chart shows the
percent improvement by enabling
resizable bar we're looking at the more
realistic 1080p resolution for this
card's market first technically you can
run without it but it'd be awful and not
anywhere close to competitive with other
cards on the market with rebar on we saw
a 39 improvement in performance and
hitman 3 on dx12 22 uplift in the
division 2 30
in tomb raider red dead 2 and dx12 also
about 30 and horizon zero dawn with
those and even 16
uplift in the old gta 5 on dx11 strange
brigade with both vulcan and dx12 was
within error or close to it but
everything else had at least some
improvement for some perspective games
that are heavy on vram will see the most
impact from this strange brigade is both
too optimized and also not really that
intensive on the memory and so you're
just not seeing much of an impact there
at least for average fps this though at
least sets the stage for our competitive
benchmarks where with intel we're going
to be running tests with both rebar on
and off because
it basically doesn't work without
resizable bar you can just throw it in
the trash
almost let go of it there this chart of
the same comparison is for one percent
lows the previous one was average fps
but all results in this one were outside
of error and were a notable uplift the
time required from one frame to the next
to get it to the screen is what we're
looking at and although average fps was
impacted up to 39 by rebar one percent
lows are greatly benefited even further
red dead shows an outlier result at 441
uplift so we'll need to investigate that
one closer in a frame to frame chart and
we truncated the scale on this chart so
that's why the bar goes off the screen
because otherwise it just minimizes the
impact of the other 12 results and makes
them look meaningless as for the rest
the lowest improvement we saw was the 21
uplift and strange brigade with vulkan
enabled and this is a game that saw no
benefit in average fps the other results
showed uplift in the range of 70 to 80
percent and tomb raider was doubling for
the one percent lows in our testing to
really understand these results we need
some frame time chart so this is looking
at the frame to frame interval and the
frames are measured in how many
milliseconds it takes to draw a frame
that's each peak on the graph coming up
and lower is better but more consistent
is best this is the closest empirical
representation of how the game feels
that you can create in a benchmark
anything else like bar charts they're
easy for a lot of data but they also
leave some of this information out so
let's get to it here's the answer as to
why it was so bad in red dead and other
games with poor performance without
rebar the frame to frame graph plots the
rebar off results spiking upwards of 300
milliseconds at times meaning it takes
about a third of a full second to even
get the frame to the screen most people
can see excursions from the previous
frame in the 8 to 12 millisecond range
so even someone who's never played games
before will see a 300 millisecond spike
this is bad and if this were how the
card behaved at all times it'd be dead
in the water as a result and something
we would never recommend average fps is
relevant if the overall experience is
choppy and stuttery and that's what the
blue line represents now with rebar on
things are actually fine so it
completely negates all of the statements
just made and it actually becomes
okay it's best that we zoom in though so
you can see just that set of data zoomed
in the a380 still isn't perfect but it's
certainly way better when rebar is on
the on results were typically around 22
milliseconds with three excursions and
those spiked to about 42 to 58
milliseconds now that's still bad to be
clear and it is noticeable in gameplay
as a stutter or a hitch but the
difference is that this set is playable
behavior while the blue line is
completely unplayable so we have enough
data now to see a trend and basically
say yeah rebar even though it's not
technically required
it is rebar does not show this type of
impact in amd and nvidia from what we've
tested
they're typically in the range of zero
to a couple percentage points uplift and
average fps sometimes it's even
technically negative because it's
basically error and so it's a lot
different story there now as for how
this works resizeable bar plays the
biggest role in performance when the cpu
is writing to gpu memory or technically
reading although that's even less common
how frequently this will happen depends
on the game as with red dead we're
seeing at least one astronomically bad
frame that basically ruins the entire
experience no matter how many frames
you're looking at ultimately and with
other games it might be less obvious
than that with just more sustained bad
frames over the course of playing it so
uh this is something where
intel's card thus far seems to be the
most sensitive with memory latency on
the cpu to the gpu memory rights and one
of the things to know here is that intel
has done something different with its
memory controller or its memory
subsystem design and this is something
we're going to see in our benchmarks
where we test higher resolutions even
though they're not really playable they
serve as a good function task for the
card and paint the picture for me what
we're going to get from intel in the
future time for some competitive
benchmarks in shadow of the tomb raider
with dx12 we measured the a380 at 50 fps
average with rebar enabled allowing the
amd rx 6400 a lead of 14 in average fps
the lows are about the same between them
the 14 lead here is significant because
if they're priced equivalently it makes
a better argument for the 6400 although
we also don't really recommend that card
overall but comparatively those are the
only two options it's doing better
compared to the 1050 ti oc from 2015
which isn't actually overclocked here
that's just how msi titles things the
a380 leads this by about 36 percent in
average fps and it has a good lead and
lows as well the 1030 is irrelevant both
here and always but if they're anywhere
close in price the a380 would be far
superior as for the gtx 1650 and the
1650 super both have significant leads
over the a380 the 1650 super is about
200 on amazon right now so 60 or about
43 more money than the a380 is and more
than at least the a380s theoretical
price of whatever 130 to 150 dollars
similarly it's 44 better than average
fps so it's about a one dollar to one
percent gain for the 1650 super so thus
far intel hasn't flubbed totally here
it hasn't impressed us yet
but it hasn't well hasn't impressed us
by failing miserably either so
that's good
for a new vendor at 1440p the a380 runs
at 34 fps average with rebar that's not
particularly playable but out of
interest it helps to see scaling between
the resolutions the rx 6400 is about 10
percent ahead here dropping from 14
percent ahead at 1080p intel has clawed
back some of that gap although with this
particular set of options in this game
it doesn't realistically matter the 1650
super maintains about a 43 lead and the
rx 580 is about 38 ahead here intel does
a lot better than this one in f1 2021
the intel a380 ran at 43 fps average
with our ultra settings for the test
suite that doesn't particularly matter
and you can make this card run better on
this game by dropping settings to high
but what matters is always is the
relative scaling so we'll switch to
percentages the rx 6400 loses in this
one the a380 holds a somewhat staggering
22 lead demonstrating a scenario where
the a380 has a design and an
architectural advantage the a380 also
beats the 170 to 180 rx 6500 xt here
leading by seven percent so in this one
amd is getting embarrassed so far the
gtx 1650 non-super so a card with a 150
original msrp leads the a380 by about 19
that's better than the a380 has any
business doing overall based on the
previous result and it gives intel maybe
a glimmer of hope but
it's not really quite there yet at 1440p
the a380 runs at about 31 fps average
leading the rx 6400 by 17
that's less of a lead than before but
it's still a lead if you scaled down the
settings to medium or low which wouldn't
be worth it but would enable play the
a380 would do okay here the rx 580 has a
massive
70 lead and again if rolling the dice on
a used card that probably came out of a
mining farm doesn't bother you
it might be worth rolling the dice on it
if it's a similar price to the a380
given those two i mean it's that 145
dollars for five it feels kind of bad
considering it was 200 to 250 originally
and it's been quite a long time
but
in far cry 6 at 1080p the a380 with
rebar ran at 54 fps average the lead
over the non-rebar results is massive
showing this intel specific behavior at
play the 6400 ran about the same level
regardless of rebar holding a reduced
lead of 10 versus the a380 it's also a
little more expensive in theory anyway
so that's a better position for the a380
relatively than one of the previous
charts like tomb raider the price
equivalent but used rx 580 would land
you 26 ahead not nearly as dramatic as
the 40 percent we saw in tomb raider and
the 1650 super is about 35 percent ahead
here losing some of the value
proposition seen previously sadly the
2022 a380 only leads the gtx 1050 ti by
about 11
and we dug up our receipts for that
particular 1050 ti and we paid 160 when
it was new six years ago at 1440p the
a380 isn't playable for far cry 6 with
high settings it's not a big surprise
but we can use it synthetically the rx
6400 leads by only 2.4 percent here
showing that it is possible for the a380
to encroach on its competition it just
needs the right workload or the
competitor needs the wrong one rebar has
no impact on the 6400 here next we're
gonna look at gta now this one is extra
interesting this time specifically
because it's an old game and it's on
dx11 which is going to be intel's
weakness dx11 is where nvidia arguably
has the best drivers right now and
it's able to punch through competently
all of those extra abstraction layers
that you get with dx11 where it's less
direct to the metal than dx12 or vulkan
and intel will have a hard time fighting
that because nvidia and amd both have
decades of history building relevant
drivers not the
igp ones that intel ships for cpus but
actual drivers that get updates and mean
something so for intel whenever it's
competing in a title that isn't brand
new or in the future that's where it'll
have the hardest time fighting and gta 5
along with lots of other old games are
still popular today the a380 ran at
about 34 fps average here at 1080p with
our settings the gtx 1050 ti embarrasses
the a380 running 77 ahead at 59 fps
average it's playable but intel isn't
even close to the same price by msrp
card from six years ago if you want to
play the inflation game the 1050 time
might be worth a little bit more now
than it was back then but if it's still
six years old it just doesn't matter the
position is also out of rank with
previous results illustrating the
expected weakness in both dx11 and an
older game the rx 6400 leads the a380 by
a staggering 84 percent not even close
between the two even accounting for
intel's gain or lead and f1 and any of
these lost there
it just doesn't make up for it the intel
card right now is a little bit
unpredictable i mean we could predict it
based on the api and the age of the game
but it's relatively unpredictable and
that matters
that's something that for a computer uh
not many users are willing to put up
with here's 1440p intel does poorly the
rx 6400 leads by 84
next game next up is rainbow six siege
at 1080p this one has the a380 at 120
fps average with the non-rebar version
doing well on average fps but doing
poorly in point one percent lows the
a380 leads the 1050 ti by 28 tier the
6400 leads the a380 by 13 and the 1650
super has a 48 lead with the 580 leading
by 38
and this is with dx11 so at least intel
is handling this one better than gta 5.
at 1440p the a380 remains in playable
territory despite the high resolution
that's the first time in the suite so
far this card runs ultra settings at
1440p at 75fps average that's a 33 lead
over the 1050 ti so an increase in the
lead versus 1080p the rx 6400 is more
interesting it's now at 76 fps average
and reduces its lead to basically zero
percent or error the 6400 is struggling
to keep the same distance and pacing as
in the lower resolution scenario the
1650 super maintains a 44 lead and the
580 drops to a 30 lead from 38 intel
might have some secrets in high
resolution gaming out of a curiosity we
ran a reduced suite with vulkan as well
in this one the a380 leads the 1050 ti
by 41
up from 28
but the a380 is still doing better in
dx11 with this game the rx 6400 ran
about the same performance as the a380
but it was variable across eight test
passes the 6400 bounced between 107 fps
average to 117 or so something we didn't
see in the other tests we included
strange brigade mostly because it has
both dx12 and vulcan giving us another
unique api comparison opportunity in
dx12 the a380 ran at 73fps average
allowing the 6400 a lead of only 3 to
5.5 percent depending on rebar that's
far reduced from other charts the 580 is
about 41 ahead here the 1650 super about
25 i had in this one reduced from
elsewhere so the a380 is doing
comparatively better here than in some
of the other tests with vulcan the
results fall from dx12 so the dx12 api
seems to do overall better with this
game interestingly the a380 does swap
and start leading the rx 6400 and yes we
did ensure vsync was off it's just
coincidence that the cards landed this
close to 60. in strange brigade at 1440p
dx12 the a380 ran about 53 fps average
leading the 6400 now by 5.6
as a reminder the 6400 led by a similar
amount at 1080p so intel is gaining
ground at the higher resolution once
again in the division 2 at 1080p the rx
6400 switches back to a lead this time
of 13 over the a380 the a380 is about 40
ahead of the 1050 ti with the 580 about
46 ahead of the a380 interestingly at
1440p the 6400 drops its lead to 5.3
percent from its previous 13 lead this
continues to reinforce the higher
resolution improvement in relative
positioning for the a380 which we think
might be attributable to the same
behavior that's influencing this rebar
performance in red dead redemption 2 at
1080p and with dx12 the rx 6400 leads to
the a380 by about seven percent not as
impressive as elsewhere the lows are
about the same between these two cards
other than the non-rebar results in
being disastrous the a380 leads the 1050
ti by 62 in this one with the rx 580 31
percent ahead and the rx 580 and a380
are difficult to predict relative to
each other since we've got one with
poorly developed drivers and the other
one is the a380
just kidding sort of the a380 is still
developing but the rx 580 is old so
predicting them is hard only for the
academic exercise here's the 1440p data
the rx 6400 now leads the a380 by 2.2
percent down from seven percent at 1080p
neither is playable but the value is
understanding the behaviors just quickly
tested in 1080p and with vulkan the rx
6400 now leads by 13
instead of the previous 7
vulcan throws another wrench in the mix
that makes it hard to predict overall
scaling for a relatively new vendor to
the gpu market and our last test here is
power benchmarking where we look at the
power going into the card at the pcie
slot and on the pcie cables to get a
total board power for this one we're
seeing the photon a380 at about 82 watts
and the rx 6400 is just far more
efficient in the 50s watts range even
though we're not really that fond of the
6400 it is out doing the a380 in general
for efficiency except you look at
something like f1 2021 where it loses
it's a bit different story so intel's
got some ways to go here perhaps it'll
be a different story when we look at the
a750 or maybe once if if we look into
transients it might be better but
transient spikes don't really matter
here because the power consumption is so
low anyway wrapping this up then a
couple interesting findings here first
and foremost rebar basically required if
you cannot turn on resizable bar because
you're running an older system and you
just wanted a drop in card upgrade this
isn't it
it's not going to do it for you it
cannot compete even remotely when rebar
is off and even worse
even if you didn't care about competing
you still run into the problem where the
frame time consistency is sometimes
abominable when rebar is not enabled so
that's number one thing second part is a
pcie lane count we're going to look at
that next
where it would only really matter if
you're running pcie gen 3x8 versus say
pcie gen 4x8
but for most platforms
pcie gen4 is available if you also have
rebar available so it's kind of lower on
our priorities list if rebar weren't
basically a requirement then we'd be
much more interested in that angle one
other thing here we noticed that in high
resolution tests like 1440p actually
even 4k which we didn't show even though
it's not playable it's not practical
most of the time
it reveals an interesting behavior which
is that intel's arc gpus
they start to gain performance
relatively versus competition where
it'll climb a few percentage points
towards or past things like the rx 6400
and while that's not really actionable
because if you're not playing at 1440
anyway because it's not really quite
good enough you don't benefit from it it
does tell us where intel's going and we
think this is related to rebar behavior
where because of the
unique memory subsystem structure that
you're using and the reliance on memory
latency it may be the case that we see
these gpus doing the architecture doing
better with higher resolutions than say
1080p
so it'd be more like nvidia than amd
right now in that way the biggest
problem that intel's running into with
the a380 and probably every other arcgpu
at least in the initial lineup is
definitely consistency the behavior is
erratic and it is based on a few
different things one of them is the api
if it's another one is the age of the
game another one is the driver the level
of optimization of the drivers for each
specific game and these things all kind
of tie together so
directx 12 and vulcan are on most modern
games it's what they're built with for
the api older stuff on dx11 dx9 so we
saw gta
really
abysmal performance for the 838 it
wasn't even close to the rx 6400 in that
game made no sense at all
uh to use an a380 for gta 5 and that
probably resonates with other older
games it definitely resonates with other
older games as well especially those on
older apis so that's the biggest
challenge they face is consistency and
it's hard because nvidia and amd have
been building these drivers for decades
intel has built one driver package that
sucks for gpus that are terrible for
probably a few decades but you wouldn't
know it that's the igps if you're
curious so they don't have quite the
experience and
fortunately so far we haven't seen
marketing pretending that they do so at
least there's that so 6400 from amd it's
150 160 card right now it's 7 to 14
ahead a lot of the time sometimes it
allows the a380 though to lead by 20
like an f1 so it's all over the place
right now you are taking a little bit of
a risk if you buy intel arc but it's new
and it has to get established somehow so
someone has to take that risk intel is a
huge company it does have a lot of
resources on this and the roadmap does
have at least a few more years
in the works with at least one more
generation being worked on right now
that would be battle mage so
if it gets abandoned at least won't be
for a few generations if that's any
consolation other things to be aware of
so the rx 580 if you're okay with the
used gpu
personally speaking uh rx 580s are old
enough now and they were heavily enough
used
uh especially in mining at this point
that i would feel uncomfortable buying
an rx 588 gigabyte they are on ebay
they're like the same price as something
like this is and they massively
outperform it but you are rolling the
dice a little bit on either getting
scammed um who knows maybe artesian's
former ceo will uh sell you one and then
somehow recall it oh and there's the
rewall the performance versus the 1050
ti isn't particularly impressive either
sometimes
it's like 11 ahead it's just
it's not really
that exciting considering that's a 2016
card so
our opinion on this ultimately the a380
there's a reason intel didn't launch it
worldwide immediately there's a reason
they relegated it to one market they
chose china for this market everything
will sell there's a massive audience
there and
that reason normally is because it's
just not competitive enough or a supply
issue it's one or the other but we're
leaning towards given intel's history
probably they want something a little
fiercer to launch in the rest of the
world as their flagship and
now it's basically going to be forced to
acknowledge that this exists because
media is starting to get it so the a750
would be the one to really look out for
as far as should you buy it so basically
no um
it does better than it really you would
expect in some games like f1
it's just that consistency is the key
where if it's not consistent that is one
of the most frustrating experiences for
an end user so who should buy it right
now as an enthusiast someone who
likes being on the cutting edge wants to
play around with something new and
different and interesting and
has the patience to deal with some
frustrations because you've worked on
computers enough to know how to deal
with it
strictly from a value perspective so the
card as in the video card not just the
gpu this is much better built than 160
150 rx 6400s
that you can get for the same price or
more so that's embarrassing for amd and
its partners where they're shipping you
basically a piece of paper for 160
that
is it's just not well built so intel or
at least gunner partnering with intel
has that going for them maybe they're
taking lower margins on this because
they have to compete whatever the case
may be at least the card itself is built
well we'll look at that in the teardown
but in terms of competition uh for us
it's kind of in that maybe camp if you
are not experienced with computers
troubleshooting or you're helping
someone buy who isn't this is not for
them it's too early if you're
experienced with it we think it's
competitive sometimes
it's just it's hard to make a firm
recommendation though just because it is
kind of all over the place so anyway
it's a good start for intel any company
coming into the space like you said
can't hand it to them and say okay well
because you're small
it's a way a weighted scale and so if
you're 30 behind then suddenly you're
equal we can't do that
so
it's good that intel has a good foot in
here the drivers have to develop and
mature more and so does the architecture
let's see what the a750 is but that is
your first look at it for an in-depth
test and we have many more coming this
week so subscribe for all of that that's
it for this one thank you for watching
go to store.camerasaccess.net to help us
out directly and grab one of these
limited edition cyber skeleton shirts
and you go to
patreon.com for behind the scenes videos
and some written updates that i've been
posting we'll see you all next time